and welcome to punch-drunk sports where
winners win we are we have a full studio
we have a lot of people coming we got
people who are gonna call in and talk
and in the studio our two guys they're
on a wonderful podcast you can see their
podcasts and hear all their stuff
they're featured on the punch-drunk
sports.com website they're very funny
guys please welcome to dirty sports guys
we got Andy ruther and Joe pray know
everybody how are you
routine pray know Lutheran pray now and
join us from whatever foreign country
New York is this foreign country that
foreign country of New York my good
friend Ari Shaffir dude you got a shave
you got a shave it's not looking good it
looked really rough it looks like your
your you've been held by Isis for a
month
oh you can't shave with a beer you can't
scuba dive with a beard it's just like
[ __ ] gets in there so you gotta use
Vaseline around the edge of the beard
and I was like let me get some Sun on
this [ __ ] anyway I bet you took
a little bit of Vaseline off your
[ __ ] put it on your beer you're good
to go yeah you know what I mean all you
do is like [ __ ] some salad or
whatever they call it these days toss
salad back and by today we call the
eating salad no just like Ari cuz you
got do the this angle we're looking up
that giant two nostrils and it's making
everybody uncomfortable there we go
it's just ha ha ha that's where the
cocaine go call it a god shot that's
called a god shot this ari where you
gonna be where you gonna be I'm gonna be
in Washington DC The Improv January I
mean June first second and third nice
guys got any date you want to push I'll
be up in San Francisco and Oakland this
weekend do you have day what where it's
the set up in San Francisco laughs City
in Oakland set up two shows on Friday
last City Saturday okay awesome
we got anything I'll be getting herpes
from a harmony date this weekend perfect
dude Oh
great oh well that's well they're gonna
up the game dude it's competitive on
goes there goes the Rio Pond the eat
harmony adds Jason you got a dates
I got a do a profile account on okay
stupid where it's all dumb girls and
just like my my tube partners in crime
all of us will be at skank fest in
Brooklyn
I believe the 11th 12th 13th where we'll
discuss this yeah mom July July yeah
where we will be discussing this after
your date Sam after that 40 minutes
uh-huh we're gonna be winning a
three-on-three tournament with ease oh
yeah wait the three of you guys were
playing against kill Tony try to get
Steve Rannazzisi which we will not let
them we're at a three-on-three
basketball tournament punch-drunk sports
versus legion of skanks versus kill Tony
versus there's one other podcast come
town I can't lose to come to three on
three a single elimination tournament
not all at once stop 14 be hung at at
one time which would be be awesome it's
Tony
Redman and Josh Martin I believe I would
have 70 blocked shots in that game 70
okay I'll aegis Kang's who we cut who's
covering who I mean I don't know escapes
the only tough one is big Jay because he
plays like a [ __ ] frat white frat
dude Center so you you'll have him I I
know I'm gonna end up covering him to
get out of his [ __ ] Kenya King Gomez
play
no but he's dirty he might bring like a
knife or something man yeah you know
Puerto Ricans too yeah I wouldn't trust
him to save more lives yeah yeah sorry
shoot free throws with brass knuckles on
I have to go to I have to go to 24-hour
Fitness star shoot my threes man get
back to that Armenian sat I just need
your dirty ass [ __ ] shady defense
that's all I need that's are you gonna
play you gotta play in the creep glasses
oh yeah yeah maybe I'll get some cream
yeah
yeah boggles dude no layups that's we're
playing old Big East basketball yeah you
got to get a headband and a headband and
a your yarmulke don't tell me your
secret my ball on the post just our
walking backwards we get rid of whether
they are ease there we go
guys June 1st I am going to be at Cobbs
in San Francisco for the the tinfoil hat
comedy night
Eddie Bravo myself Trez mala out of
Vegas and we might be having a very
special drop in Tim Dylan from New York
so you might be dropping in yeah and off
the grid I wish we could sell out
tickets let me make my life [ __ ]
easier but go get I wish I wish I'll
take anybody at that point yeah thank
you dude and then Sacramento June 2nd at
the punchline now here's the thing I've
been pushing tickets for the June 1st
one and we've sold more in Sactown so
make sure guys if you go buy tickets I
know Artie's there soon to make sure you
go to the Cobbs comedy website go to
their actual website because if you go
to these third-party websites they're
gonna Jack you for cash it's like way
more expensive so make sure you go to
the real ones and then tonight we have
comedy chaos and I'll be home for a week
and a half so if you're enough state New
York you want watch you have C fight
with me let me know so that's it man
that is the Bears net the next what I
just I think it's interesting that the
Sacramento Show is selling better when
the San Francisco show has and this just
in breaking news and Orion is on that
show on every show Sam's doing in rogue
Sacramento is a big conspiracy town I'm
sure that you think San Francisco would
be too well sacrament the conspiracy is
Sacramento is a real city oh you don't
like
it's what's holding female comics back I
think it's their acts yeah breaking news
Ari Shaffir that's a least of my
problems
oh I do have it another game on apply
that forgot I I just saw next Wednesday
I'm at the Venice underground Ari's
there any big comics it's gonna be on
there dear breaking news about who's
gonna be on my Venice underground show
next Wednesday 16th next Wednesday next
Wednesday oh yeah oh dude that's
actually bad news you see his car pull
up it
what's Jay Davis his show on Melrose the
part of the parlor parlor hold on is he
still doing that I thought he's done I
think he's booking the Laugh Factory
buddy's booking laughs actor but is like
you know two months ago or something so
I'm doing the parlor yeah and [ __ ]
Chappelle's driver pulls up right on
Melrose and I'm like oh that can't be he
wouldn't come here and do this here -
would he sure as [ __ ] he might still be
onstage those two months ago
why would because he can go anywhere and
do anything why isn't popping up here
and then like three of us the last three
comics is like yeah we're gonna have to
rebook you yeah that's what it does yeah
uh who was it man I was doing a show
with Steven Z's comedy juice and like
everybody was somehow it was bumping
everybody like people didn't have
credits juice right there you know it's
just like ah dude I do got a voiceover
on a cartoon he wants to go up early
like what do we Steve it at the time at
a TV show yeah and they're bumping and
Steve wouldn't bump me so he's like [ __ ]
hey I'm not gonna go up we're just gonna
go but it's just like you know it was so
funny even if there were a lower level
than the people that they were over
listen Bert Kreischer is killing it but
Steve Rannazzisi said the funniest thing
cuz like
we're like we're like like we've all
been at the Comedy Store for like 20
years man and there used to be like when
you were performing and you got like a
handed a piece of paper saying who's
next
it was like the face of a network a
famous movie star or honey and you know
it's be like oh it's Eddie Murphy and
people go nuts so so Stevens Easy's
performing and they're about the hand
they Jeff hands him a piece of paper and
Jeff okay he's like oh we got a very
special guest Steve gets all excited
look sup he's like it's Bert Kreischer
like is this real real you know it's
like a bird crusher and still the place
like those two guys that Tom Segura and
Ari think that was [ __ ] brilliant man
but so funny like who is I don't know
where that story's going by this point I
died hard thank you guys for letting
that story die oh that's hot that was on
ice I didn't know it's over breaking
news Ari Shaffir Bert Kreischer is fat I
know we're gonna have this debate if we
get into that well let's get it real
quick because we were talking about it
right before we started the show we got
an update re ready breaking news we have
an update on the SAT that ruther has to
take oh yeah no I didn't listen ok so I
signed up for the June 2nd SAT yeah oh
you so you haven't taken it down
pay for it for it and everything I get
this email from SAT support good
afternoon as part of our commitment to
ensure we don't need the whole email
game uh suggest ok my [ __ ] girlfriend
like I don't need sent June 1st at 9:27
p.m. ok basically this is what they're
saying you need to be attending a
college or university and apply for
scholarships financial aid you need to
complete this form to be considered to
take the test so I I filled out this
long form and had to i basically lied on
everything good instead I was applying
to UCLA yeah all these different schools
and then at the end it said legally is
this all accurate
because we can use this against you and
I clicked yes and 100% of the Internet
and that's a [ __ ] legally yeah so I
don't know they said they will decide
within seven days if I can take this
they'll say you should have just said
you identify as somebody that's going to
college next year that's what I'm gonna
do I'm gonna say that is brilliant
right yes it'll be like there'd be like
oh we're done yeah
I identify as a Native American yeah
wants to go to college now you should
identify as a Native American bisexual
trans seventeen year old who is Filipino
that's what I'm gonna like [ __ ] you on
the SATs now yeah what what what can
they say if I take that approach which
I'm gonna do and say I identify as a 17
year old high school student you know
what can they say back right or you
could go down and then you sue that and
then they also said I legally can't
disclose it said you legally can't
disclose your test scores on social
media what like what's good luck what
the [ __ ] is this that is the dumbest
thing I've ever heard my life say that I
don't know reply it's like if I don't
get to take this I'm gonna identify as a
school shooter I'm gonna identify but as
[ __ ] have you been practicing now no
problem in fact I trigger is going into
this without even giving up hopefully I
even I've even paid the extra fifteen
dollars to sign up for the essay for how
much did it cost to sign up it was 45
and then 15 for the essay so so GoFundMe
cover those pocket but I'm actually
worried to go into the test speaking of
school should I'm the one who's worried
I might get shot right like I don't
wanna be walking to a high school on a
Saturday like Kevlar for everyone yeah
that's that's true that's true no
they're really they're they're they're
aiming for the dumb ones I think
shooters are organized if nothing else
yes that although that would that's a
daya that's what they laugh if I die
taking the SAT that'd be great for both
our podcast yeah yeah that would be
really what else our numbers yeah yeah
and I'd get a new host that'd be great
yeah yeah would you want to replace him
it's a great question list your top 50
like you haven't thought about it
obsessively yeah I think I think I think
it would obviously be Maddie Goldberg
immediately what about Rogaine or
Chappell yeah what about Yoshi breaking
news alarm just said if you die he will
be the new go oh no I just had the kill
ruther also breaking news a Rogen tech
sorry back fast now since we started
talking about bets
I got hit when people found out I was
coming on the show I got hit with so
many messages about my hot dog and they
all said tell Sam ask Sam about the hot
dog he blocked me okay I got like 50
people that said they yeah you blocked
got a block belt a black belt for sure
what is the hot dog thing I'm supposed
to wear supposed to shove a hot dog up
our asses because my team [ __ ] the bed
last year so we're supposed to what not
sure oh you mean gentle like work it
slowly I have to do some poppers to
loosen that [ __ ] no just put coconut
oil it's a great lubricant just yeah
yeah that's such a creeper thing creeper
it's coconut oil on there tip and shoves
it in girl's butt hole I didn't say
butter
all right I'm telling you you gets their
Lube at [ __ ] tre Foods Trader Joe's I
know I use the Trader Joe's coconut oil
it is great and it's great for jerking
off you go through before you got the
coconut oil yeah no azulene me manage
dude I'm telling you get it it's a game
I can't believe they won't let you in a
high school take the SAT so weird
that is yeah I mean so you sound like a
perfect guy at the back of a high school
room one more time yeah ma thinking
about doing it very soon but I want to
do it off I won't do it on camera
ah maybe wait hold on hold on Sam as the
constant judge of what's fair in these
things there's no there's no rule you
got to do it on camera that's not a
thing that's if you want to do it off
camera I mean I'll call you a [ __ ] but
that's totally haha
that's totally that's doing the best for
sure I am I'm what about to do nice on
camera but obviously not the answer I
don't want any audio because that's the
problem yeah when I when I was on the
hook for the bat to think think thanks
to the Falcon actually I actually want
my concern if I did my concern with is
if I lost and I was on camera is like
you would see the facial expression to
me going I've been missing out on hot
dogs on my ass for 45 years yeah what
else is shaped like a hot dog that would
be awesome
we know any women that openly talk about
liking in the but I you are asking us
that yeah you don't know any women that
openly talk about that I'm not saying I
don't I'm saying do you guys know
anybody any female comics oh he's like I
like it in the app you know like how
they're so free they're like not I'll
stop Miami nope nobody throws it out
that you think it would help their
careers nothing yeah no you can't think
of any I'm not thinking about any mean
comics feel female kamo you said girl
doesn't know who that are into anal but
I can think about sevens Josh Martindale
oh he likes it in the pot Justin right
now
why is he loving how about that no what
why is why I guess I don't know how to
start it I think a couple years ago he
just gets pegged really my wife we ought
the [ __ ] just making this up I'm not he
talks about it where what there it is
okay there the fake news goddamn Ari
fake news yes I'll only do it if it's
how Johnny's the one shoving it in my
but that's it that's it Johnny then how
do you heat up the hot dogs
what's the I'm sure of the hot dog I was
practicing for like four or five months
I thought I was gonna lose and it's like
I tried it all different ways but the
fun one was bacon-wrapped the break
bacon-wrapped bratwurst was was where
I've actually found the most pleasure so
hold on so I mean I'm thinking about it
has to be cold right I'm throwing a
condom on that yeah just for the
firmness yeah I want that breaking in
your ass yeah condom on a condom yeah
for it freezing re you're just it's
gonna just shoot through like a bobsled
through your [ __ ] you can't see me
just it's like when you go down a
waterslide yeah you know a little bit
like pack of hot dogs has 12 hot dogs
but there's only eight buns it's like we
solved that guys just shove four of them
in your ass this is gonna be the sound
you're gonna hear Ari's ass as the hot
dog each other but what was the man what
was your guys that Falcons Raiders
Cowboys best regular season record Wow
and it came down to the week seventeen
yeah and he had that Carolina but then
we let him out of the bed yeah we almost
blew up in my face it almost love my
face man it was I was like no who's
gonna have to do it except for me and
that would have been a hell on earth God
think got a cowboy suck thank God
they [ __ ] inside I can't believe nobody
wants tez bribe they wouldn't even give
him a [ __ ] well he'll good job he's
one of those guys but he's not a locker
room leader you know what I mean he's
not not bringing in like a Antonio Gates
or someone that's gonna help your young
receiving took or so and he doesn't
warrant that much cash now cuz he can't
get separation anymore that's not good
but somebody ain't going into campus
gonna realize they have a recieving
problem somebody is gonna get injured in
camp and they're gonna he's gonna get a
job in like August so you think his jobs
now gonna be like going down the middle
if he can't get separation I think he's
just gonna end up being like a regimen
Plaxico Burress where it's like they
throw to him four times a game they
throw them for fades you know when
they're inside the 20 and that's it
who's the guy that Giants just cut a
Brandon Marshall he's gonna be a pain in
my side yeah exactly that's exactly what
it me man that's got and probably took
the same amount of disappointment as
well right yeah that didn't work out at
all so you don't want to give a guy like
that who's on the hook for like eight or
twelve million and now somebody offered
him three and he turned it down
who des Marshall does that yeah the rave
turned down 3 million gallons that's
stupid so I got that and and the NFC
East was like we've seen you play
Breville we're good yeah yeah we're
gonna miss Dean yeah yeah exactly
exactly exactly so he's uh he'll get a
job somewhere he's one of those there's
a lot of those guys Antonio Gates is
another one Julius Thomas receivers that
played for his gate not as gates not
currently signed yep exactly right god I
just got it Wow and dude that's it you
got a tight end or if you have a young
tight ends absolutely guy to come in and
and gives you two years of just even if
it's just film study but it'll of a [ __ ]
you know I mean let him let him catch
five balls for 44 yards and you know if
you go to tight ends in the red zone or
something
yeah Gates is so smart enough that me he
probably had eight nine touchdowns last
year I think I only had three really
yeah yeah like four hundred yards and
three touchdowns or something but still
it's like that's productivity if he's
not your main tight end right because he
brings so much football knowledge I feel
like the Cowboys have gone
now with wit and retiring but like the
last five years it was always like hey
let's find the guy who's gonna replace
Whitney and then no one ever replaced
Whitten surprise might end on the team
I feel like gates yeah well he
essentially retired after the draft did
you guys see the picture of Witten's
hair versus like a year ago and now no
basically his hair of course the
internet just puts him on blast the
minute he gets his gig he's a zero hair
basically a year ago and now he's on TV
something yeah and he shows them to the
press conference was just like a
perfectly matted head of hair really
yeah nothing just showed up full row
like Jeremy Piven was like 25 and
completely bald yeah yeah is like 45 and
that's great hair
yeah Piven yeah no he's nice guy dude I
met him he's a nice guy
yeah really cause you met him I'm sorry
how else am I supposed to know what kind
of person I've heard Holt nothing but
horrible ways about him really yeah
really good how many [ __ ] people have
you met below when he says what he meets
them but he's [ __ ] [ __ ] your
girlfriend first chance they get okay
all right I'll reserve I'll reserve glad
I brought that up I've never met him
so Arya are you excited about your
Yankees dude they're killing it right
now they're on fire yeah three out of
four against Houston that was a [ __ ]
statement did you see and you gotta call
this up overall this Chapman closing out
against all two of they call this up I
don't know what that term means was me
calling on the [ __ ] get it on the
[ __ ] screen dude those three strikes
down the middle and 101 each one to
[ __ ] in the game they're up one run
he didn't even pump his fist at the end
he just stopped
stares at him he just stares out I'm
going like this is the new me man
you're never gonna touch me this is the
new ACH mean it was [ __ ] deadly that
guy should be a Liberian warlord if he
wasn't a god damn close ups I'll get
these Asians off our screen we're giving
[ __ ] nuts
alright just real quick before we get
back into baseball yes a I'm a caps fan
sort of and they are in the East oh yeah
I'm hockey sweet love watch this
[ __ ] watch this wow that's a
cut - he took that's a two-face I cone
to a [ __ ] kidney Gardner what's the
score in this game right now six five
six five - guys the person second
runners I'm 1 & 2 that means if he gets
a hit right look at him look at him get
the ball again - one more there we go
someone's feeling touching me now watch
this [ __ ] beast of a face whoa hahaha
bye Felicia he's got that he's got that
are all dis chat men pitching in may
face yeah very different than they were
all this Javan pitching in October face
I want them to bring back when they're
the postseason
thumbs down I think he had that same
face when the red sign didn't realize he
had to go live in Cincinnati from
[ __ ] Cuba yeah no [ __ ] to me actually
probably is an upgrade okay maybe
Cincinnati everybody yes upgrade from
anything ever even a third-world Cuba
it's nothing a push you know me being
from Cincinnati pray knows but nothing
but hard on the whole state of Ohio I
just I just said Ohio has no personality
whatsoever listen anybody that like I'm
just saying if you think Ohio like
Indiana people always get about Indiana
I'm like you think Indiana you think
IndyCar racing you think basketball when
you think Ohio what do you think like
what it we think like swing state court
I think like Ohio State I think Football
Hall of Fame abs I think Cleveland's can
be another under a city and Emily ties
that's right Alex P Keaton that's right
re I'm saying
proves my point right like it's the
third thing on your list it's like an
80s sitcom that was shot in a studio in
Los Angeles but Pedro Carrie
Marge Schott Marcia racism could be a
chili
you'd have flaws so you like Nazis so
broadly that was that was Ohio man
that's where you guys PCP from that Ohio
PCP never been in Cincinnati good eye
there yes it is shady ish I walked into
Chipola I'm like this is a Tripoli from
the wire we're so [ __ ] hood well you
were you and over-the-rhine I don't even
know I was opening for Joe Rogan and I
feared for my life you I guarantee
you're an over the ride it's clean
doesn't Haber humble dress the Rhine set
it on fire i I like Ohio
I like ocean anymore in Cleveland
Cleveland's great I do like Cleveland
the back back in the day chicks put out
when I was young
Ohio girls in general put out yeah
they'll have your baby yeah they're like
[ __ ] you I'll raise it good luck thank
you tell us your job yeah they're
looking for a way out yeah they're like
will you pay throw me a couple bucks
once a month take care of this [ __ ]
Florida's like that Tampa - they will
Florida will [ __ ] you the swing state
girls yeah how about getting garnered
votes so Ari are you gonna go see any
games while you're there any uh baseball
games yeah that is an Austrian
Australian football's the best dude the
footie it's funny crazy it's so fun
how do the rules differ I have yeah the
combinations like rugby in it football
yeah yeah it's like it's like more fun
it's more fun it's more fun rugby it's
just basically more fun rugby okay
and yeah I was in Australia I went to
the state of origin which is like
after their regular season they play
they they separate all their Pro players
into where they're from and they play
like a regional game okay which would be
awesome like I don't know why we don't
do that in basketball like all them make
all the New York guys play like all the
[ __ ] California guys but they do that
and then they play a three-game series
and regardless of who wins the first two
they still play a third game so if
somebody like sweeps the first two
they've won the series then the third
game is just like this bloodbath
yeah because like we already [ __ ]
lost now let's just kill people yeah
okay Australians it's like you get guys
like you'll get like Kevin Durant and
Steph Curry you know or let's say better
draymond Green and Steph Curry like oh
like teammates for a while then they go
and play on other teams for state of
origin and they'll punch each other in
the [ __ ] face yeah
and they take it so much more seriously
Wow they jump on each other and then
launch off of each other to get higher
oh do you go seen as what I saw so so
that play right there taking a hit to
make the catch you got to make the catch
otherwise it's not a mark so it's big
you can't just like get it later here's
the deal so at halftime they had the fan
thing three fans come out a dude puts on
his back a fake mattress and goes can
you take a hit ball high in the air the
fans gotta jump up and the guy with the
mattress backs up into him so he takes a
hit right the first guy couldn't make a
catch open three second guy makes the
catch falls down knocks himself out on
the ground
Wow that out cold out the first one to
see him like he's out he's done that's
why I was trail is so much better than
here if that happened here that guy
would sue yeah you know this footage
like those Three Stooges play efficient
playing for multiple punches Oh just
brutal see that's what they mean see
they say if you got rid of all the arm
equipment head it would totally change
football that's I say I would look like
this
yeah and uncool that yeah I like dude
why if we like they got rid of fighting
in hockey
who's calling for this is it that we're
so desk
for women to watch this like women don't
like watching guys fight women love that
barbaric [ __ ] to man oh yeah wait there
they're fighting there's no fighting in
hockey I don't I don't watch hockey
there's no fighting they like they're
trying to legislate it out dude I think
I'm sure we get killed but there's not
fight like you always hear Melrose Larry
or whatever maybe like they used to just
now they jump in like somebody gets a
hold of somebody they jump in to break
it up somebody gets you know now guys
are getting penalized for like you
started it yeah and that's two separate
penalties yeah are you guys hot by
people now hold her for a little while
it's a better like strategic move so
like he holds him down for a second and
the guys trying to get up and the guy
standing above them just kind of goes I
just punched it in the face that's why
whenever I play footy I cover myself in
coconut oil I am leaning towards doing
it off camera no cameras no nothing and
I know cameras yes how deep does have to
go that's the question coconut oil can
be used as a lubricant both during
foreplay and sexual intercourse how deep
does this have to go that's my question
I until your [ __ ] closes well then I
was back along do I have to jerk off why
do it that's optional but I'm not gonna
say no Johnny shoves up my ass and he
does a reach-around I'm in oh listen
this guy thinking about this oh you're
telling me I have to say I now take anal
I think after doing here's here's what I
think should be the measurement whoever
has the smallest dick that you lost to
it has to go in at least that far I'll
be hard yeah I got six
what do you got re-what I have a
six-inch dick on its tippy toes why
don't you just have a doctrine well
anyway bigger than that have a doctor do
it have it have it medical minister
covered in Obamacare yeah the budget for
a doctor who else is done professionally
I mean our stethoscope if that'll make
right that was I said I would take our
II didn't soft not frozen and it's
hanging out of his ass I'll take a bite
of it MVP's I feel bad that I'm left out
of this I think you should do it while
I'm taking the SATs just combine the two
bats and it's all set yeah that nun
distracts those kids nothing like a nice
[ __ ] 50 year old shoving [ __ ] hot
raw hot dogs in his ass
hey are you 40 years old that guy's
shoving a hot dog that's quickly answer
walk as a trans with a shock collar
routers in heck they come will shock and
I'll shove the hot dog a little deeper
yeah you trust me there's gonna be so
much action going on you're you're gonna
be welcome to get a 300 in English that
was gonna be the most embarrassing part
of the day will be just the hold so it
would be like no way that deep this
isn't [ __ ] rape not doing hot dog
rape on the [ __ ] shell it's gonna be
deep enough that we all agree but what I
half-assed it just go just what happens
play on words yeah I mean you already
ghost of a hot dog in your ass Triple E
just [ __ ] go yeah it's never
happening to me willing to do it
get my ass raped demand again firstly
the Dodger dog do the super Dodger dog
oh I mean they'll all be like a Tex
Avery cartoons are you gonna do a year's
gonna be kosher or your dogs are gonna
be kosher
oh no not kosher nasty nasty
I don't like Turkey dog I don't want Ari
later in life that look be like you know
what maybe I'll go to rabbinical school
or something and I call that one video
of me shoving a non [ __ ] kosher dog
in my ari if you go to some Yankee games
or even go check out capitals you should
use this seat geek app yes seeking for
all your ticketing needs everybody
that's right really I have it on my
phone I buy tickets all the time same I
think
profits of rage are coming so I'm gonna
be looking into that I went saw k-rock
Cray rock almost acoustic Christmas on
shrews really it was the greatest
[ __ ] show I've ever seen my life
brother prophets of rage run the jewels
dude you know who got me maybe it was
the shrews but I thought they were way
better than expected their convenience
but hotdogs people's own convenience
[ __ ] what I was seeing a concession it
was a thirty seconds from a horse I
thought they were way better than I was
expecting way better
um Queens of the Stone Age dummy dude
murder and it was so interesting because
prophets of rage annihilated uh who the
[ __ ] prophets of rage
they're basically Rage Against machine
but they sing Christian folk music
machine Public Enemy and he'll and dude
they all together all together one fan
pieces yet
oh it's so good dude and he opens up his
like these are dangerous times and when
dangerous times you need a dangerous
song and this is the most dangerous song
of them all happy birthday so I got I
went on a seat geek and I got that dude
can we look at Sikhi care you got it up
you got C geek up here look at that all
the options right now it's a great app
ah it's really easy man now listen if
you use the promo code punch-drunk
today that's our promo code it will get
you $20 off your first seat geek
purchase man so you can get everything
dude fights anything yeah you get
fatigue Eames I bet you can get some
leads your skank shows tickets yeah
uh-huh
I heard if you drop that promo code you
can go to the live viewing of the hot
dogs in your eyes you should put it on
there now five dollars bio because
people are gonna film it yeah that's
that's exactly what you've been saying
you don't want to do that's exactly what
I'm thinking dude ari we're looking at
tickets how much you looking to spend
how much that money 30 bucks a ticket
for Yankees A's that's where he's going
to yeah I'm going to I'm gonna see the
A's tomorrow up in Oakland I bought my
tickets on see cake oh you did no but I
haven't been I'm trying to go to as many
ballparks as I can I've never been to
Coliseum so I figured I said I'm going
up oh dude you're gonna enjoy not having
fun city yeah that [ __ ] play I know
I've heard it's terrible but I haven't
been so before they tear it down I'll go
to those real shitty yeah I've been
there but the Astros were there and it's
a day game tomorrow Wednesday day game
against the defending champs just like
that you know I'm excited for you dude
I'm going at the end of June up don't
you
Dodgers Cubs here not in Chicago but
singer beware your Cubs hat yeah yeah
but they take over everywhere the Cubs
yeah every stadium yeah we went last
year we we got I was [ __ ] [ __ ] out
of my mind that's when I didn't leave my
seat the whole game I was on edibles we
sat in the bleachers which I'd never
done it's the best Cubs Dodgers
dude you know though I think it's right
field Pavilion is all-you-can-eat so
it's like 45 bucks
unlimited hot dogs which I know these
guys would love one for your mouth
one for your ass one for UMS hot dogs
nachos popcorn soda waters and maybe ice
cream Oh nachos dicey nachos yeah
maybe i screamers unlimited you just go
down and there's just piles of
everything yeah it's a good deal and
it's all available on SeatGeek so go
there check out all the all the
different use it saves time and money by
searching multiple ticket sites and
compare prices and find amazing deals
and you get more bang for your box seat
geek rates every ticket based on value
to help you immediately identify the
best seats to fit your budget Plus every
purchase is fully guaranteed so you can
shop for tickets on Sikhi quick
confidence makes eek-eek your go-to app
for finding the best deals on every type
of ticket sports concert comedy and hot
dog shoppings not talk shoving what give
me the lay down on these what does it
calm down because I'm not worried about
I'm not worried about leaving the skanks
I'm not worried about losing this case
and I'm definitely not worried about
kill Tony oh they're hipsters according
to Wikipedia so they're gonna be playing
in dress shoes and black socks is how
you're telling me that's a win you can't
lose for those guys that punch of
Windsor's hands down around i'm only
shooting shots behind my back when you
guys get back after taking care of
everybody it's gang fest we'll play you
guys I'm gonna tell you something they
see you guys I wouldn't be worried if
there's like you guys in the basement
yeah
Jason Tebow's
well I'm gonna be first of all smoking
the entire time yeah game cigarettes my
mouth but I'm gonna have I'm gonna add
12 block shots a game after I put on
Twitter twelve blocks shots a game
against these [ __ ] nine Yahoo's and
what I like about it this is the first
time in our seven-year history that the
three of us are joining forces and not
trying to kill each other yeah dude it's
like Voltron of love yeah I end up being
friends after all
three-legged dog go in the [ __ ] war
what are they what are you playing the
games - ah - one guys I hope it's just
like first one to score we shot they
would have Smith to see any good for
Legion Skaggs is Smith any good Oh Oh
see I think he would play with all them
before and they're all sort of okay
that's better
but we're better than that yeah like I'm
confident that we are the three of us
collectively have way more basketball
experience than the other nine kill Tony
doesn't have a guy over five nine yeah
yeah no we should beat them I'm telling
you Legion skanks is the only tough one
I hope we don't draw them the first
round well there's only one three chance
we do so yeah it'll be fine
maybe you want maybe you want him in the
first round get him out of the way good
to get the hard one out of the way yeah
maybe we should do rote we should rotate
just play his own defence let one of us
take a break
that's who again who all go two against
three that's the box and one but the
ones just resting the Bob Bob will call
it bong in one so one guys hitting the
bong on the [ __ ] side then the other
two are playing D we're gonna easily win
that I'm gonna be what one is it July
I've gotta get I gotta get into the gym
shooting three no you down the beach all
the time lately yeah well we're down and
come down and shoot around guys oil each
other up yeah
coconut oil coconut oil coconut oil from
Trader Joe's but we definitely bleach
your [ __ ] don't you I've never please
I have a disgusting hairy [ __ ]
I would not believe ya
the Rhinos probably got a [ __ ]
moccasin yeah yeah I tie my [ __ ] hair
to my dick yeah that's great your hair
looks like the 1990s John King head
first I should shave my [ __ ]
to have this same mustache that uh
because we got a guy who's about to call
in who wants to weigh in on it Mike
Ricker but this goes basketball playoffs
are in full effect I think they started
out how kids are playing great the refs
[ __ ] suck I agree with you on that
shot for the free-throw line
two to one this whole series sorry would
you be cool with if if the Celtics
traded Kyrie for DeMarcus Cousins right
now no at the end of the season you
[ __ ] okay I think that'd be a great
move for both teams right yeah I mean
you could move al horford to the floor
he's not a long-term guy Kyrie would be
great yeah I'd be happy with that so
then brats and then Kyrie would play
with Anthony Davis and holiday yeah how
they could be your - yeah and then
that's it that's my rule that's a win
for each team my real one in bit with
the pelicans you have to franchise
players I mean I think I think the the
Kyrie is the better
I think Kyrie is better than boogie
long-term but but look at what Brad
Stevens gets out of guards
he turned Terry Rozier into Kyrie Irving
yeah I mean Isiah Thomas wasn't yeah
yeah but but my point is he here wasn't
that's he's like Mike D'Antoni type
where it's like it he can if he can turn
you into basically that guy then why
what do we need that guy for if you know
Isiah Thomas was nobody was on the
Celtics was an MVP candidate now is
nobody again yeah it's not like that
didn't just happen
no it's like Brad Stevens gets the most
out of those guards so [ __ ] it downgrade
at the guard spot
keep these guys playing like they are
and so I read no no I'm saying
though is it country's the future that
franchise no I don't know about that I
read and I think they're going to but I
like that trade I would I mean like no
he's great but he's basically like I
thought he was in profits of rage
so boogie cousins should be the greatest
player in the league if you look at his
skills oh yeah you look at his skillset
he is like the evolution he should be
the next level of like from Shaq we're
Shaq was could hit shots from the
outside but could dunk on everybody now
you got to Marcus cousins who can step
out shoot threes almost be like a point
Center but he's brain is so shish-kebab
yeah but if I'm New Orleans I realize I
don't need I don't need cousins I spend
better without him we need we need
shooters we need people who can hit
shots and I've said before and I've said
this basically when the beginning of
this warrior team was put together I
this there's been about six natural
scores that I've seen we're like make it
just close your eyes throw it up and it
will go in and three of them are playing
right now which is Kevin Durant Steph
Curry and Kyrie Irving you know so they
need a Kyrie Irving down there then the
question with that is Kyrie already
wanted his own team from LeBron James so
now he's gonna go and he's gonna be
Anthony Davis the second guy that gets
other teammates and do it he's not that
he's not that guy he was like needs be
another one guy I don't see that at all
the problem with that I saw that really
didn't kind of manifest it but dim was
that I think Kyrie saw that this year
was just gonna be like it's LeBron
leaving is LeBron leaving and then if
LeBron leaves Kyrie stuck in a ghost
ship you know and now you're just
waiting to find out what this guy does
now I also heard through one of someone
who's got a major NBA show on TV that
rumor on the street was is that LeBron
banged Tyrese X or his girl
which is the total caps move right it's
like the Collatz letter the cats the
shoe in the Simmons theory right like
it's either it's all every argument in
the NBA is over girls or gambling yeah
like that's it that's all they were
fighting over it's unbelievable you have
all the chicks in the state of Ohio the
[ __ ] there's like 15 you can't but
you're also you when you're an NBA guy
the first thing is like is this [ __ ]
gonna talk like that sir your first
thing like so that that pool gets so
much smaller when you know like oh she's
already [ __ ] an NBA dude so she knows
how to [ __ ] NBA dude
certify these hoes yeah we need to start
certifying the hose in there like all
NBA hose you know yeah well it'd be a
first team All NBA Cup sign an NDA
before you [ __ ] along hey dude you know
on Twitter puts checks by people yeah
these chicks are five [ __ ] verified
that they they're gonna shut the [ __ ] up
and you know you could sue the [ __ ] out
of them that's what verify yeah that's
why you're verified cuz you gonna take a
dick and talk I tweets hilarious by
their by garnet
that's what kill Tony's new shoes they
just which one is that one Jew grande
wanker oh that's right that's one all
right you gotta really start working on
that Judah big Jay before though we're
gonna be the light you go through the
bag of bats and decide which ones people
still want to do what they don't look if
you like seven years into this you don't
need a spreadsheet for your [ __ ] bike
loser gets their mom [ __ ] by the other
two guys my mom has since died since we
started this bed yeah which reminds me I
still need to go to the Insane Clown
Posse concert dressed as a [ __ ] and
y'all juggle and you were also supposed
to we could go to mine that is the real
bat you're also supposed to spend a week
as a trump supporter in all make America
great again stuff and Trump shirt that's
right when I lost I lost I turned my
hair purple like the day it happened you
got like you got like four bets hanging
in the wings this is the welching side
of the table over here
wow you really [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah that's
what that's what I do get Sam on social
media
if I don't do something right away I get
don't tag you and be like brothers a
welter just like trippin
these guys have old bats forever and I'm
getting [ __ ] I get yelled as a
[ __ ] angry about it well they just
lock it yeah exactly
if you mention hat dog any hot dog and
he [ __ ] emoji your block I don't care
my mom gone can't even mention dogs you
can't mention hot day nothing nothing
hammertime
so uh so as always ah
there comes this moment in any NBA
playoff run where we got go with the
LeBron is the grace of all-time
somebody commented I can't I comment and
then smartass [ __ ] magnum p.i here
has to come on and [ __ ] go with this
argument that we had at the end of the
last playoffs in which I felt I
decimated you thank you and now we're
here again talking about is LeBron the
greatest of all time not just like he's
I think we all agree he's the greatest
of right now for sure but easy the
greatest of all time I don't know where
you I know you have them pretty high up
I don't know if you great except Jordan
I think it's very close one and two with
okay well I think it better than JJ
right AJ Radek and then it's like and
then nobody and then nobody and nobody
he's a it's Jets playoff Reddick which
is [ __ ] shit's getting tight and he
can't shoot I got LeBron higher than
bird I got LeBron higher than magic I
know I mean it's fine I've got LeBron
higher than everybody and I'm not I've
always said this like I'm not a liberal
I wasn't a LeBron fan I'm a Knicks fan
so when he went to the heat I was like
[ __ ] this dude like I hate nothing more
than heat right
I've [ __ ] on this the state of Ohio and
the city of Cleveland endlessly I've no
there's nothing about him that makes me
want to refer him except that I've never
seen anybody with his skillset dominate
the NBA like this and I understand
here's the thing Jordan was the greatest
basketball player of all time and when I
said that people would be like Bill
Russell I go look I get he has half as
many titles as Bill Russell but he
wasn't doing in the 60s he was doing it
in the 90s and I get that LeBron James
has half as many titles as Michael
Jordan but he wasn't doing in the 90s
he's doing it in 2018 when we're talking
about the unicorns of boogie and Kevin
Durant and Steph Kurt like guys who are
doing things LeBron - 159 LeBron
averages 150 a night in the 60s a
hundred 50 points a night Kevin
if Kevin Durant watching I can walk for
that if a Kevin Durant walks into a gym
but in 1880's they shoot him on sight
because he's like some sort of freak
creature they're like how was he seven
feet tall
yeah right right talk so then [ __ ]
let's switch any LeBron James his team's
right with you let's early Duncan teams
right in the Spurs and that [ __ ]
insane Western Conference he had to go
through you're delusional if you think
he makes it to the finals it's not
happening what team you put him on wait
wait what do you mean yeah what are you
saying teams from this district
conference I'll even give you a ride me
he was the batter we're arguing his
entire team not LeBron we're going the
entire Miami Heat 2000 new live is that
that Tim Duncan did everything LeBron
James has done yeah yeah in a smaller
market in a way tougher conference so
you not only got to the finals but won
five or six shouldn't one the six one I
don't know why you're screaming I don't
know why hold on first of all you always
have to take it bro Barclays on that
son's team take everything in context
first of all Greg Popovich is arguably
the greatest coach of all time but he's
made mistakes he made it right Tony
Parker the furture no come on the first
year hold on the first year that they
loved Tim Duncan Tim Duncan's like in my
top five all-time Tim Duncan's fantastic
yeah LeBron James whole era
coexisted with a a dynasty Spurs team
which he beat wants which he lost you
twice he will he beat them he beat them
in when he was in Miami on a super team
notion but he had the worst team he
actually lost them when they were they
had a better record and they were
favored that's not the only time right
I'm lost when he was late but my point
wait wait Chris Chris Bosh crispa but he
did but also your but you gotta count
everything in the in the context of the
situation
Duncan when he should have lost the
Dallas and he lost and that's it and
that's literally the only the only one
that you can call him honest and Dallas
and also the Jordan but Jordan did it he
just didn't do it in the finals because
the great teams in when Jordan played
also in the East so he lost the Celtics
lost to that he didn't make dude
the Cavs never have played an all-time
great team in the playoffs getting to
the finals that's why they've been
denied right and that's where they face
Orton had to go against boy yeah and
that's why he lost them yes right here
all right great so we're all so hold on
we're all on the same page here both of
them lost two all-time great T yes right
just Michael Jordan did it before the
finals of Ron James did it in the final
yeah but don't know understand so the
notion that he's gotten to the finals so
many no I'm not even talking about that
I'm talking about his look at what he's
done just in terms of taking everybody
he's he's still a guy that went to the
NBA Finals beat Duncan beat a 73 when
Warriors team he beat he beaten OKC team
with Durant harden and Russell Westbrook
all playing together and Ibaka he's
beaten great teams are he beat teams in
the finals that are better than teams
that Jordan beat in the finals
Rahil also lot of dams in the finals
that were on the part of teams at Jordan
lost two before the finals it's the
exact same thing to walk the Eastern
Suites the East is the East is weak
right and that's how LeBron gets there
and the West is weak and that's why
Jordan didn't lose ever to the West he
only lost two great teams early that's
ridiculous to say that how do you
you made the [ __ ] east heart LeBrock
would not been to so many free I agree
with you I agree with you but it's not a
final stood okay in the finals
there there were do you have an all-star
game we're [ __ ] it was coming down to
the end of the half or the end of the
game and LeBron had it and he passed it
off and Kobe's like shoot the [ __ ]
ball yeah
why because LeBron [ __ ] tightens up
it's another game also symptom of what
was going without also this I also
disagree because I think the reason I
have a LeBron James is the greatest
player of all time and this all happens
in hyper speed no first of all he
doesn't that's a [ __ ] his last
disappearing he's been an eighth fine
he's about in his eighth final in a
Rossi [ __ ] shop
damn it gets home on did you watch this
last year he's not watching it all dude
he disappeared Summer League bath he
disappeared in this last year in the NBA
Board issued against the team Toronto in
that great against the great against the
greatest team before this series started
everybody on the show is like LeBron is
gonna lose to either Indiana or Toronto
but do you understand any sleep
surrounding like its Toronto they suck
yeah we saw yeah think they may be great
but was that key they're King [ __ ] on
turd island wait what about the 73 win
Warriors team that he beaten the files
led both teams with the in points
rebounds assists lock steals he
dominated right sees everything and he
people exact team ever seen any B's oh
he didn't I bet he's number seven you
don't make number seven let me just read
this that because everyone what everyone
hates that they want to bring [ __ ] up at
they hate their sit like this
game-tying or go-ahead field goals with
ten seconds left in the postseason this
is all time Michael Jordan is seven and
fifteen Kobe's 5 of 22 LeBron is 12 of
23 so this is all time so this myth that
he's somehow cringing under pressure is
just a [ __ ] line ruther you are
revisiting Heiser you are crunching
numbers numbers don't [ __ ] for you
only slow you only have why no but this
is a fax you just you just said that he
grew her you don't have under pressure
well sir this Oh Lucy does the shots
there are times where he didn't even
show up last [ __ ] game fine the dude
playing his position is lightening his
[ __ ] team up it is an elimination game
he doesn't cover they put Richard
Jefferson because why how could he cover
him why would he cover him because he's
the guy killing him that's no that's
like saying widen widen widen Jordan
cover bird why did it wasn't this
position kept Michael Jordan Michael
Jordan is six six Larry Bird is six
eight
it's not his position LeBron James is
the point guard LeBron James is the
point guard of the Cleveland Cavaliers
shut down dude he's a bit snoot no
Michael Jordan is of all time shut down
defender because he guarded Jeff
hornacek
Craig Ehlo Hirsi Hawkins daddy's we
danced Marley where where show me show
me Michael Jordan garden call Malone
Peyton HAMP Bernie you're revisiting
history nobody that knows anything about
basketball that would say Jordan wasn't
a great [ __ ]
he destroyed Clyde Drexler destroyed him
destroyed his legacy okay
LeBron James Boyd in destroy his legacy
because in destroy destroy
hold on destroy Clyde Drexler is legacy
cuz Clyde Drexler got a championship the
year Michael Jordan took took a break
because Michael Jordan can't play 15
years without a great years on white
great argument well probably cause he
gambling yeah probably because of
gambling and all that was the first time
dude I was the first time nobody's in a
second time he just he was like I
mentally broken from going to three
straight NBA Finals he's like I can't do
it anymore I'm mentally and physically
swamped I can't do it
LeBron James lasted that he's got an
eighth he's played the in the last eight
post seasons he's played all the games
hold on the only time it is and first of
all time first of all the Dallas series
is the only [ __ ] in LeBron James armor
and let's remember that know that Dallas
Antone
was too they were finals the fruit when
they lost the first time with with Andre
Varejao and Anderson Varejao and [ __ ]
Mo Williams was even doing it those time
dude
they'll do any no Miami Miami but when
he when they play the Spurs what three
times in the finals yeah right all right
matter actually beat them once no he
played them free once really early yeah
hey I beat them once lost to him once
early and lost him the last time so
we'll even throw out that first one yeah
of course you should throw out that
first time what the [ __ ] even doing
that no doubt yeah okay there's two
after that where he lost the first one
he was favorite hey dude it's too loud
dawg all right where you Vietnam yeah
all right so sick of this conversation
who got into over hell accomplished but
the matter everybody loves to pull up
the Mavs Series meanwhile that Mavs team
beat the defending champion Lakers by is
it even closer wet them they shouldn't
even wore D before they shouldn't even
have been the [ __ ] defending
champions the [ __ ] refs gave that to
the [ __ ] in Boston if you look at Game
seven Kobe [ __ ] the bed and they went to
like 25 to 5 to the foul line
it wasn't the the the NBA why the
storyline is Kobe gonna go for a six
that team wasn't even good enough dude I
agree with you but my point is like
let's not [ __ ] on LeBron because he lost
to a Mavs team that was like loaded with
everyone it was rhodamine who the Heat
were a better team that was the perfect
storm in that nav serie yeah they were
favored because they were the Miami Heat
today was heavily favored again LeBron
yeah and they lovely favor and then
LeBron then they got [ __ ] lucky they
even made it to their finals because
draymond Green should have been kicked
out when he [ __ ] but you're using all
these at this is what I hate yeah
exactly
let me ask you this right now I dare to
say the man should have won cuz he
should have been kicked out and the yes
trip he shouldn't even have taken on the
Golden State Warriors because he should
have been kicked out when he nodded
[ __ ] Steve Adams by the time before
but they knew they wouldn't get far
in that team into the final let me ask
you let me ask you this if draymond
Green does not get kicked out in that
series the [ __ ] Warriors win there
and LeBrons ybk he beat him two more
games with draymond
yeah but they kick him out any changes
the [ __ ] momentum a meanwhile
meanwhile in the Bulls Knicks series
Phil Jackson's going has anybody ever
heard of Joe Joey English no great go
out there punch Derek Harper in the face
and we'll win this series he's just he's
letting Phil Jackson sending guys in to
start fights with charge good yeah as
you should
I'm just saying there's a whole whole I
think Steve Nash and the Suns Amar'e
Stoudemire gets [ __ ] suspended coming
off after Robert Horry excellent run
where the sun's maybe when that's all
about if sin babies we don't do that
it's not like if sin maybe yes it's what
did happen what has x in the first place
there's nothing to do with a game play
you can't say that's a you guys all play
basketball in the finals that game too
[ __ ] let you guys all play basketball
and you're all gonna play this
three-on-three thing and I play
basketball and like I look at the game
and I go if I'm gonna pick one guy to
play with forever that I've ever seen
I'm gonna take the guy who's a better
shooter a better rebounder a better
passer a more versatile defender a more
unselfish player with more longevity
that didn't quit twice that didn't get
hurt all that went twice he quit against
the Celtics
no he literally quit his mom that's
literally quit he quit why stop playing
he's drawing up Jordan quick that's
literally quick walked away twice I'll
clean wet Series and through the [ __ ]
series he through the series everyone
I think pray knows question which i
think is always a good question
everybody should answer if you could
start a franchise with one player are
you gonna take the more complete
all-around player which LeBron
straight-up is he's a weasel I would
take Jordan I would take Magic Johnson I
would take Kareem abdul-jabbar I would
take
Tim Duncan so take the [ __ ] young
Shack over [ __ ] LeBron I would I
would I would you take because magic and
LeBron are very similar in their game
why would you take why would you take
magic over the Broncos magic makes
everybody better so does LeBron know you
got the fraud is taking garbagemen
LeBron through the [ __ ] eyes back it
doesn't
why is ever gonna running from why did
[ __ ] Kyrie want [ __ ] out of there
dude he literally took because in the
garbage man to the final choice people
remember this conversation
Matthew doused in the final but he won
but no games against Golden State with
Matthew Dellavedova but if you're Kevin
Love he had no Kyrie Irving he had he
had no business winning did the wrong
have any business winning two games
against Golden State you are acting like
I'm saying he's not good I have him as
number seven that's so crazy
because he all times all the great
better but here's the problem when
people rank people like this is your
you're just picking and choosing like
how is Jordan above Russell how is
Jordan above Kareem how's Jordan above
magic it's all it comes down how is it
competition okay great and how you
LeBron James playing against the best
competition dog [ __ ] you're yet oh [ __ ]
if you're not you're not actually
telling me playing against Bill Laimbeer
who would get laughed out of an NBA jury
is more difficult than playing it warm
endurance two days in all time T that's
it's an 80s in 80 believe me your wives
by his peers because you can't touch him
except here well here well he beat he
beat Durant's team when he was on ok see
okay that one then when when they won
Kevin Durant row and a 73 win team it
was very difficult for LeBron James in
beat that that team
I get it he's out gun you the guy play
in your position destroys you they don't
play the same position that's [ __ ]
they both play scoring for it are you
[ __ ] no app first of all LeBron
first of all LeBron James is essentially
the point guard of the vocabulary
he beat him that was hard in the fan
Ross second here
first championship and they were know
all those guys together
I think the point pray know is trying to
make it I know we always say on our show
is for some reason basketball is the
only sport guys where we have this
hard-on for the 80s and 90s where we
suddenly want to talk about our Jordans
karate
we're not we're Jordans grown people
talk about Jerry Rice all the fun but my
heart said let me talk about Lawrence
Taylor in football they do it all of you
but it's not my place my point to say
British women if you look let's talk
about those Knicks teams if you look at
the 90s you just you can't compare guys
like John [ __ ] Starks and Anthony
Mason and Charles Smith and Charles oh
they're like these guys aren't in the
NBA they're just not even plankton so
the argument is LeBron is dominated
named a seven Nick Ramos named it you're
not playing during the stop play they
are playing they mean name name one guy
in the NBA right now who's the bruiser
who can't shoot name one right now Ibaka
who's a star bucket is a star easy
Japanese garbage but he's scarred do it
he's not a bruiser exactly you're ours
right him was a [ __ ] a very very poor
poor poor poor poor 99 cent version of
LeBron James it was a first Anthony
Mason yeah we had seen a 6-10 guy with
[ __ ] handles yeah elbow jump shocking
Larry Johnson could [ __ ] [ __ ] great
Larry Johnson would be in today's NBA
Bill Laimbeer would get laughed out of a
gym Lambie right Ehlo who would guard
Michael Jordan would be laughed out of
the [ __ ] Joey
610 yeah how tall is [ __ ] one regular
six for six
Allen Craig Ehlo and there are six for
shooting guards okay they're out where
are my six for white shooting guards I
can't defend anybody
but hold on hold on hold on by the way t
look at that swear bird jumps up and
punches a guy in the Lakers in the face
absolute is not part of the game anymore
right so you don't need a bruiser
anymore yeah yeah I completely agree
with you but the idea that like hand
checking was what was gonna stop the 69
275 pound NFL tight end turned best
player ever in the 80s is like a [ __ ]
joke and that's regular exist it was an
all-star they you know let me arse back
Forrest Wood it got hit going down
LeBron would have hit them back there's
never been a specimen nobody's seen what
are you say the question why how is it
like ron has everything yeah but when
it's in the finals against the best
teams and and he realizes it's the way
he checks out that's not you are banned
away that's just not sure can beat the
India that's like say Michael Jordan
gives up against the bad boys pistons
and Michael Jordan gives up against the
Celtics
because Michael Jordan's not Michael
Jordan could win in the first round
Michael Jordan Michael Jordan lost to
Sidney Moncrief
and the Milwaukee Bucks in the first
round Moncrief Mike Dunleavy near Harry
Cummings dude Sidney Moncrief is an
all-time ru LeBron Lawson Dwight Howard
in the [ __ ] Orlando Magic that
started JJ [ __ ] Redick yeah JJ Redick
choosing dude
we've already had discussion at the end
of the day we'll see how it goes with
that we've had it for three weeks in a
row I just think to me to me the thing
is always you're basically like true you
if you go to let your getting upset me
ye he's number seven but I said you were
the seventh best of anything in the
world of all time cuz I do be thankful
because I got if he's the first pass
yeah exactly
cuz I think it's just kind of a it's a
weird thing that people do I don't know
why everybody wants to take down a guy
who has proven it time and time again
you know I defended what your and this
on I've said is you're disrespectful to
the guys who played before and it's a
rule man
the sizing right now yeah the same way
I'm disrespectful to Beiber's the same
way I'm disrespectful the [ __ ] Ted
Williams it's like I'm not or nor
[ __ ] any of those guys LeBron I'm not
comparing Michael Jordan I'm complete
all the eras and destroyed all-time
great absolutely it's disrespectful it
but you're doing the same thing to Bill
Russell then you're doing the same
things will change
yeah exactly petition LeBron which is
why the competition is the best it's
ever been that's the argument the cut
but he's making he's wonder Stan every
other sport the athlete is better than
it's ever been
can we agree on that church history
evolution evolution progression that's
that's [ __ ] that's how it works
there's seven foot one shooting forward
exactly exactly
there was a two seven sodas an NBA in a
six yes what basically the brain was
trying to say is that the argument is
LeBron has dominated the sport whether
it's the best it's ever been just like
in any other sport if an athlete
dominates style of play the style plan
the 90s was true pointers and [ __ ]
bumping each other and Pat Riley getting
garbage men to the he's recovering final
style its place when you play you play
it yeah thank you we agree yeah
absolutely
so you are telling me that you think
LeBron James yeah went through a [ __ ]
Eastern Conference that was as difficult
why what Jordan did but why yes sure I
already answered that before what I'm
saying is he played in the finals that
he won but LeBron came against the Spurs
against the worries LeBron could play
any sound
LeBron could play ninety style he could
have played eighty style with that body
type in the way first couldn't I don't
know that but I did you wrong could I
know Lamphere Gooden I know Lam beer
couldn't today how do you know that
that's right we're gonna do everything
that he was good at is negated the way
they do you play right now but you're
acting like lamb burger couldn't change
his game like he couldn't know the lamb
there's gonna be Rik Smits is suddenly
like [ __ ] kristaps porzingis like it's
just out the way it works
why has porzingis done but it's done
nothing my point bringing up a guy's
done nothing in the league are because
than one you don't know where he's gonna
go he's named close to being the Greek
freak no I completely agree my point is
he he can exist here at seven foot one
white guy like Rik Smits has no place in
today's NBA yeah that none of those guys
do just look up lamb beers numbers
that's all I'm saying
yeah that's great look what inin beers
number it's like saying it's like saying
a guy it's like saying Dick Butkus could
exist in two in today's NFL
what do you don't know what this is yes
big bucket would be lamb parrot they
said if you could add anybody in NBA
history to the bad boys who would it be
and lamb beer said without question
LeBron James right cuz he hated Jordan
they hated [ __ ] Magic Johnson no he
seemed from this era right now okay
that's great the best answer this
question is basketball as a sport in the
NBA is it better from is it better than
it's ever been
I think the style play is [ __ ] you
guys watch 80s
yeah but you know or are they more skill
aren't they more skilled I get what
you're saying the games change but
they're more skilled they're more
athletic than they've ever been more
complete yeah I mean dude like are you
who I love to death I think he's an
all-timer like dude that guy tiptoes
through the tooth and nobody hits them
yeah but Reggie Miller did that and
Reggie Miller existed it's a five yeah
but he wasn't funny see the poor man I
think I hit right but my point is happy
my point is this you can't tell me Steph
Curry doesn't exist in the 90s well hold
on when Reggie Miller is up the poorest
poor man Steph Curry right just as wimpy
just as saw it only shot threes just not
as well as staff didn't have handle just
like staff didn't play defense as well
as Steph and then Reggie was a five-time
all-star he would exist do you think if
you dropped today's war
years in the 80s that they do not win
every single game like I don't know what
who's us who's I think I love to get me
I would take the Bulls over [ __ ]
these I would I would take the razor now
you're talking you give me 90s defense
that they could play yeah for sure
you're gonna show you're gonna take your
chances that bill Cartwright's gonna
guard seven-foot won Kevin Durant in a
[ __ ] pool no no no I would put will
Perdue Dennis Rodman on oh okay yeah and
they put drawn on and they're gonna put
you're not staff you hit them and then
you're gonna put yo
so who's guarding dream on who's
guarding klay Thompson Klay Thompson's
the best player on that court all day
Bill Cartwright yeah I put clay Tompa
tax and all I got Paxton on Steph Curry
and we'll see what happens just hit him
do I'm going flourish marrow or it
wouldn't even close but maybe in the
Warriors win that that's a lot closer
than you're making is what I always say
look you go back if you go back to the
if you go back to the Olympics right
Carl Lewis the great Olympic athlete
right he want all the medals from
winning the long jump he's running the
high jump he's running the [ __ ]
100-meter he's winning the 200 meters in
the 400 meter with thanks for honesty
yeah he's doing all that he's the best
Olympian and American Olympian ever when
he stopped playing but you can't say
he's faster than the third guy on the US
Olympic team right now because he's just
not faster than him
he's just that's still win in the
eighties with Kevin Durant with Steph
Curry with draymond Green that would
still win of the eighties okay but
LeBron James can't beat that team well
how is he the best
well we can't beat the team you're
sanguine right good cuz I just named
because they have four all-stars and
LeBron James has who three on his team
go he traded away a bunch of [ __ ] see
that's the thing like LeBron to me is
[ __ ] Peyton Manning he's so good he
has too much say and he picks his teeth
and when these teams suck we blame
everybody but LeBron for putting the
team's together like he
anybody honesty pics these people and
it's just like doesn't work out come on
anybody on his jaw stood yeah yeah bye
everybody
he got Kevin Love he got Dwayne Wade he
got all these guys didn't he didn't get
he didn't get Kevin Durant when Steph
Curry lost Kevin Durant we're going
Steph Curry lost LeBron James they call
them from the parking lot to me it's the
dialogue it's like the dialogue of it
there you go we're like hey this guy
sucks he's been to eight finals how can
I say his name is shitty shitty against
the foot if he played against quibbling
Talent meaning he had anybody to go up
against who's in all time let me ask you
this who isn't alt whether you agree
with this or not who is an all time team
that [ __ ] LeBron James be in the
answer conference to get to the finals I
could do that with everybody else
sure who is it you just can't deal with
who Michael Jordan beat in the finals
[ __ ] who's the all-time team Michael
Jordan three-time the final essentially
beat the Pistons eventually no nobody
else in the finals quarter Portland
Trailblazers you're picking the e-string
up yeah that's the point the point is
the Eastern Conference is easy right now
for LeBron James to in the foot hold on
LeBron lost to that's an all-time team
in the final whispers that's it the
Spurs dear dynasties firmly saying that
that war that Spurs team was in all time
you just said you said Duncan won five
their all-time
Punky's an all-time great so you don't
you know please no markers no markers
not think they're all right Leonard
I think Gregg Popovich I wouldn't I
wouldn't put him in my top ten point
guards of all time not even close
I'd he'd be lucky if he's top 15 of all
time but what about that year what about
that new year so Parker wasn't a top
five point guard that oh he wasn't
wasn't it all five championships to
dismiss the Gregg Popovich Spurs dynasty
and say that they weren't an all-time
team and then the brink and then and
then and then to bring out the Portland
Trailblazers with [ __ ] Kevin
Duckworth Kevin dockter
Kevin Duckworth and build out of your
gun and this and then dismiss Kawhi
Leonard lecture dismissed Kawhi Leonard
and start doing like oh he couldn't be
tan moral truth is Jordan never beaten
all-time team in the fire destroy world
but he didn't world not first first
eight years but let's even talk about
that after after the Pistons finals
Edith half his career he's been in that
in the final 15 years how was it his
fault
hey let me okay let me ask you let me
ask you this
which one of these guys is not absolute
positively first-round first ballot Hall
of Famers Kevin Garnett Ray Allen Paul
Pierce who you beat all together on this
up yeah after that yeah and they want a
championship there okay so that's the
team he beat okay hold on now hold on
let me ask you let me ask you let me ask
you another who are you yelling at you
wanna podcast which one of these guys
which one of these guys which one of
these guys is in a first-ballot Hall of
Famer Jason Kidd
Vince Carter from the New Jersey Nets
Vince Carter first-ballot Hall of Famer
yeah four months before
Magic Johnson retired after I think
after trying to get me wrong after
Jordan after Jordan took care of the bad
boys Pistons named the great teams in
the East that he's beating like are we
calling these Knicks are these Pacers
teams of the 98 do they work this is
where I just like well if you're gonna
argue that I got nothing do you want to
just go you're right yeah how Dan is
right how did seven yeah LeBron's number
seven
how did he do it against we didn't talk
over each other for no reason for 45
straight minutes but he has it
Sam Sam thing anymore that was an old
thing it's like saying that it's like
sorry well Jordan disappeared in the
first round he did though has two finals
Sam the last two finals no one in the
history of the sport this is just a
[ __ ] fact has had a better
statistical finals than what LeBron has
done the last years that's just the fact
the all-around game no one he led the
both teams in rebounds points or doesn't
even lead his own team in those stats I
didn't team in rebounds and this is
against the best all-time team can we
agree the dispar seven Tripoli let me
ask you this is this Warriors team is
this current Warriors team in the team
last year the best all-time team ever an
issue of the NBA we're like a two-year
run talent-wise win wins wise they are I
would put in talent-wise
leave the talent wise talent [ __ ]
eighty Celtics and the 80s Lakers were
[ __ ] murderers talent-wise and you
know what that's fantastic they were
super deep they were both full of Hall
of Famers and they went back and forth
for a decade yeah in the NBA Finals you
know wasn't there I can kill Michael
Jordan he wasn't there yeah he wasn't
there and then both those teams got old
and fell apart and then Michael Jordan
is suddenly the king of the East the
king of a basketball where's the great
team Michael Jordan its revisionist
history and that's fine we're not gonna
agree on it dude well scout files go I
hope he wins I hope he wins
I don't number four I don't care if he
wins yeah because before the finals I am
Number Four and when he [ __ ] like
Kevin Durant [ __ ] light his team up
and didn't do [ __ ] then blamed it on
tyronn lue for not letting him cover him
that is it's just it comes down so your
your issue is that she didn't guard the
best player on the other team
even though Jordan was guarding her C
Hawkins and not pain even though he was
guarding firing Russell a notch
Stockton even though he was guarding
[ __ ] Dan Majerle not coming tonight
not Charles Barkley and man you forever
guard that guy
why didn't you ordinary car that guy
known in Carver Berkeley he didn't cover
Malone he didn't cover caps he didn't
cover coming up is it to 24 is it to 25
just [ __ ] [ __ ] comments on here
top I'm not Aaron I'm sorry dude I'm
sorry that's that's everybody tells me
y'all we miss all the passion from the
old [ __ ] punch trunks you just got it
now everybody's bitching about that to
[ __ ] about what
oh [ __ ] you too much yelling I'm an
[ __ ] this is ad style podcasting yeah
get within I'd say that's nobody in the
east podcast is Rutgers we do here in
the last what they're all pussyfooting
around we're talking over each other so
you can't hear anything I watched it all
dude I'm the biggest NBA guy there ever
was I'm in Nixon i watch every step but
say let me ask you this cuz cuz hold on
let me ask you sir we've been through
this because my opinion on LeBron has
definitely evolved I was always I was
[ __ ] team Kobe over the Brawn I mean
my opinion has a Kobe Kobe's not my
killers mine but my opinion has evolved
as I've seen the Brawn of all to like
doesn't your opinion on him evolve or no
I think mine and James is the best
player playing today when I put you just
don't think the basketballs as good as
its ever nope I just think that when you
take these individual guys they've done
as much if not weigh more than front and
that's my opinion
but then aren't there guys you could say
that I've done that more than Jordan who
Kareem correct yeah I have him 1b
that's pretty much it okay Bill Russell
Bill Russell I don't think his
competition was that I think Magic
Johnson Magic Johnson's number four did
okay so what it was I mean number three
my play is there my point is your
rankings get out of whack when only know
your might your rankings get out of rat
my ask me where these guys are like I
told you you're like okay but cream has
more MVPs in Michael a same amount of
titles same more point it has to do with
and then you're like it's like on play
then you're like it's Michael but it's
like anyone's great narrators at this
point so I do diuretic cream all the
respect he's one P most people don't
even want to mention him when they do it
he's one B yeah he could ease my three
he's my three over one a he could easily
be four-way did in college to the pros
he played [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] he
didn't play anybody get in the finals he
did sonic Suns LeBron James
[ __ ] it was only an hour Ari guys here's
the thing who's better Emmitt Smith
embarrassing I like it when you took I'd
have no real answer yeah I mean my thing
is like I'll just always go with the guy
who's best when the game is the best is
the best
I think Usain Bolt's the fastest guy cuz
his [ __ ] he runs the fastest I'm not
just gives you a one this one and this
is when he wanted but you know black
guys couldn't play World Records in the
same exact sport of the same exact
condition yeah exactly and LeBron James
no no it's a lone sport that's the other
argument out of it terrorism it's like
it's like people like you know winning
is everything so Jordan is six in oh and
the finals he like oh he's obviously the
best ever but it's a team sport right so
when LeBron goes to the finals and loses
like he did this right
that this [ __ ] 12 other guys on the
team right you know II mean so if he has
nobody to play with
and that's nobody then you said it's him
doing it right you know so I don't know
bad news no this you guys could bet on
that you want to bet on this who's the
greatest of all time go to our good
friends at Betty si.com KO punch 25 net
get you 25 $3 to gamble with I doubt
this bed is in there that's on that we
should get them to get some odds up
there for this three-on-three tournament
for us yeah yeah because we always try
you guys UFC guys no no I don't know
that's boxing it used to be a boxing guy
and then like is like boxing this plane
you realized yeah it's all rigged and
everybody every fights [ __ ] to set up
another fight and everything stealing
your money I think box triple G make
quick work of that guy you watch that
fight Johnny you can watch it Sam yeah
if he sent me a link I got the whoops
why is there no popular heavyweight
boxers oh there's a ton of them right
now everybody's very bad good American
heavyweight guys um there's a couple
what's his name John J Wilder yeah the
Bronx Bombers Beyonce Walter some
[ __ ] I just feel like every time I
watch boxing like every time somebody
convinces me that this is a fight I
watch it and at the end I'm seeing
people argue over this guy actually won
and then this guy want it's like no one
I never see anybody not a [ __ ] out
anymore yeah watch oh there's a lot of
great heavyweights right a lot of great
th I'm gonna pissed here's a big
knockout today huge news
the UFC is now with ESPN they are now
showing a bite no no no this hearted cuz
weren't they Fox
they were Fox which I it's kind of
interesting that they are they so
disgusting yeah I hate that okay explain
okay they [ __ ] on they [ __ ] on they [ __ ]
on them for a [ __ ] decade yeah
remember they refused to cover them they
refused to acknowledge it was a real
sport and now you do you know why cuz
the women's side is popular
I hate it they're gonna ruin it you have
cease making some real shitty business
hey take it take it okay I don't I did
hear that they aren't trying to put
together GSP versus uh an eight years
later Nick Nate I'd rather be Nick I
think that's a more fun fine do these
two Diaz this fight each other that
would be fun well I mean they probably
their whole lives I would love another
great marketable fight for a title if
it's Nate or GSP and so let's keep that
[ __ ] let's get that money train going
for Tago fights
my uh my thing is I I would have to root
for [ __ ] Diaz you know all the outlaw
[ __ ] has left the UFC and going to
Disney is gonna make it even worse it's
gonna make it even worse dude all right
no I'm not sure to be like the NFL I
liked him on five rid of all the [ __ ]
outlaw [ __ ] that made the sports so
great I had given the yes I hate given
TMZ SPN any kind of file you'd be
Jessica Mendoza she didn't she didn't
fight UFC she didn't play baseball
either so who the [ __ ] would I care
having women called sport sport no
actually you know what I like doing work
I think Doris Burke is great I have a
huge problem with Jessica Mendoza though
because she didn't play baseball
she played [ __ ] softball it's a
completely different sport but has every
guy that's called it played every guy
I'm with you to a color code caller Yeah
right
that's what she does okay you can do
play-by-play that's fine I mean Vince
Kelly's been you know Vin Scully started
when he was 12 or whatever so obviously
he wasn't playing minor league baseball
right right but but he's just telling me
what's happening he told me this guy
grew up on a ranch yeah Jessica Mendoza
being like when that sliders come across
like they even had [ __ ] Vin Scully
plane right now bite you on
awful color commentator Andes on HD age
what I can't stand about the female
reporters is because what they do is
they send these female reporters in to
basically talk [ __ ] to these guys
yeah because they know that these guys
can't push back right and it's done
amorphous it's done on purpose like when
they interviewed on Larry Hamilton after
Florida State loss yeah she's like in
his face but yeah how'd you do that dumb
call it's like what are you [ __ ]
talking about and only only [ __ ]
white women have the [ __ ]
how did you do that you're like what the
[ __ ] is your Butler getting some hot
light-skinned sister doing that and you
see these guys like Rozier with that
really hot like skin girl he's like oh I
got thirst of my eyes dude I love them
dude but it's just like it's just it
drives people away because when it
becomes so formatted it upsets people
like I don't know would you listen any
local radio in terms of sport I don't
know the only listen to petrol some
money nah man I can Petros would be the
best comic yeah he's so [ __ ] fast man
but the show before that is Rogan and
Rodney and it's so corporate and it
feels so out of place on that channel
because everybody talks mad [ __ ] but
don't you guys think that's what's gonna
happen then with USC on ESPN that's
exactly my problem what's gonna happen
we're broken like the William Morris yep
I mean like dude and here's the thing
that really sucks for these like they
got rid of that one female fighter cuz
she was calling for a union the fighters
getting none of that money right they
get none of that money dude when they
sent you a question Jon turns up like
you guys are all comics you understand a
little bit of like how if your agent is
a producer on a show or managers
producer on a show that they don't get
they don't get uh percentage of your
money on it if you work on that show you
know it's called double dipping right
William Morris represents fighters and
they also own the UFC so how are they
how are they handling that situation
that's interesting because they did they
be in their own interest to give their
fighters better shots right that's
[ __ ] comedy club chain that does that
as well
yeah and yeah The Improv and they
represented by that [ __ ] what's their
names
that [ __ ] that's what the Improv
stuck now and did what he cares about
them about levity in their own emotion
nobody gives a [ __ ] about The Improv
zor-el over the club now yeah now I love
it if you didn't didn't didn't one of
the agencies just by Montreal didn't
they bought the Montreal Comedy Festival
like what like that's gonna be a huge
issue too yeah I think are they gonna be
more likely to put their own people on
the show right if they are I mean it's
not like it's a competition thing but
it's like if they are then it's like I
mean how much do you put your own people
on also if you if you're one of the guys
who's represented by them and you're
like wait I can't get new faces my
[ __ ] manager owns the goddamn
festival I can't get new faces yep
hey we should we forgot to do one
important thing that we always do and
Ari gets back let's check in and see how
much [ __ ] did he get in Europe yeah no
we always have together aren't
Australian women the best do you go
there a lot
I've been there twice oh I see by Ahri's
face ari what's wrong
they're great oh you look like you took
all the acid right there like it was all
hitting and your [ __ ] piano grin was
going nuts right they'd say he had sex
with three different people I'm gonna
say two and I'm taking me on how long
were you there a while left on the fifth
I'm going higher I'm going higher I'm
going for that's I'm going for I'm for
what about one more guest I think it's
great before we're going both three
going to you're going for but is it all
you guys want to weigh in what goes well
- I think lower as a girlfriend does he
no no okay that's what a girlfriend yeah
well now I'm going zero carry he's gonna
lie
Eric's playing the loyalty card yeah I
know that yeah the answer is zero save
me the day after yelling what happened
to remember just there were a couple
chicks they're just like
I feel like it and in Melbourne I had
more of a chance where all the comedians
were there I didn't feel like taking off
a not not hanging out with comics just
so I can hook up I mean 40 year old
comedy for honestly I was gonna guess
herpes right around 38 yeah I see you're
not there yet when you get to like 42
your body throws out like a cool
dictator and it really is like you start
doing [ __ ] math like how much time do I
got put into this is it worth that or if
do I just want to go home and go to bed
and get a burrito tea it really is that
you're like man I've done there was one
girl I get my number two and I yeah
exactly and I was like I was like okay
not tonight because I just got here I
kind of want to see Sean Patton just
like it's interesting because when
you're young like women give you this
window yeah like you got get here within
this window or else it literally shuts
down but as you get older that windows
still good but you don't care as much so
you got this super short window and then
you got this apathy like it's just like
I've literally been like I got half of
that fat Sal sandwich in the fridge
[ __ ] where do you put that age at
them when you start not giving a [ __ ] I
think it's a little after 40 42 42 you
just literally go oh they don't give a
[ __ ] but you know like I have a joke
about it run like I don't want it like
[ __ ] around these young dumb girls
like I don't want to spend five hours of
my email listening to her talk just to
maybe finger just to maybe finger an
idiot yeah maybe and then deal with all
the [ __ ] yeah it's like Who I am and
then you don't even get laid cuz she's
like I'm tired fact it's like I just
wasted five hours yeah I got a beat off
and I've been asleep I never really have
yeah I mean I'm a playa I'm a big fan of
just beating off and then go back there
the [ __ ] you're doing yeah each rings
true yeah I know at some point to do
this there's been times where I've been
as recent as this morning um like
looking at my phone like man maybe I
should hit this chick up maybe like go
try to [ __ ] or whatever and then I'll
jerk off and I'm like thank God I didn't
do it yeah open
you know I feel I always feel like after
a comedy show you can't like I feel like
I'm pretty good at scouting like okay
like two drinks then we're home and then
this is on like if it's certainly the
path of least resistance it's well as
you get older women start looking at you
different you're like as you're an older
guy you say they look at you is the one
and done you know I'm saying like the
hit and quit it then it's like oh that's
the guy that you date you date an older
man he's more stable he's got cash it's
young guys you like get the freaky [ __ ]
get in get out and it just like hey if
you're free later I'd like to have sex
with you and it's like all right okay
I'll come over right now pum go yeah let
me tell you about this so what are you
just gonna come in here and just [ __ ]
you probably just all the time and it's
like weird cuz that's like a weird
double-edged sword because like I bet
you just like [ __ ] groupies all time
well if you say no then they're like oh
what's wrong with you right and if you
say yeah then you're like oh what are
you man pig it's like it's a loaded
question I always [ __ ] behind a 7-eleven
what are you talking about well guys it
was a fun half an hour shouting match
you know what's this let's go to the
what the people have said and it's 64 28
with someone else
8% but that's only 25 so we'll see by
the end or whatever what yeah you know
and people on Twitter they're never
wrong yeah what do you guys push push
where they can find your podcasts and
all that stuff dirty sports podcast
everywhere podcasts are I'm at fixer
life on Twitter Joe preneur calm I'm
traveling all summer trying to hit
ballparks and do some comedy come out
drink some beers at a ballpark come see
a comedy show listen to dirty sports yes
more LeBron Jordan yeah actually we
don't yell
much anymore I already broke candy down
Andes Andes accept it what's that are oh
you're the submissive one mr. dominant
why on the podcast all right what do you
got packages what's wrong in the back
what is that what do you got wrong I got
coconut oil you get to buy the case
that's the way Costco all right all
right doing some home improvements
anything we forgot Johnny anything we
got push Oh give it up for Johnny real
quick for doing great on the youtube go
to youtube.com backslash punch drunk
sports he's putting up video too weak
yeah we film every show now but I was
actually watching that the other day
it's hell it's a hell no if you're good
but here's the thing if you're gonna do
that just you might as well shove a hot
dog in your ass accepting gun I think
it's gonna be next time I'm in studio I
will say dude we'll see I'm not gonna be
on camera though that's the whole thing
yo but you'll be on mic just but for
creatively and what's funniest you know
we we gotta get a reaction from I'll
tell you what I'll tell you about comics
in the 80s they had already done it so
much tougher back in the day Laimbeer
and I had a hot dog in his ass months
ago probably does right now well I don't
know if you know this but uh Scot
Pollard NBA world champion said that uh
we know our NBA so I'll go with Scott
giving us the seal of approval
he actually said I know my NBA but I
want to say anything but that's fine ah
guys thanks for coming I love you guys
you guys are always welcome eight be his
number six punch-drunk sports we're
winners with